رغم هدوء ساحه المجلس النيابي الا ان
المشاورات لم تتوقف هنا منذ ايام
على مدخله يقفون ابان اساسيان من نواب
التغيير الذين تاخروا في حسم موقفهم من
تسميه وزير المال السابق جهاد ازعور كمرشح
لرئاسه الجمهوريه
سته نواب وقفوا مترددين في الخانه
الرماديه بالتاكيد لا يريدون سليمان
فرنجيه رئيسا لكنهم وبخلاف غيرهم من
التغيريين الذين تبعثروا بين ازعور وزياد
بارود لم يحسموا خيارهم على فرضيه ان
ازعور سبق وشغل منصب وزير الماليه
هن بعدهن ما اعلنوا موقف لانه عندهم قراءه
يعني مختلفه للواقع القائم اليوم عم
يتشاوروا بشكل متواصل لا يقدروا يوصلوا
لموقف مشترك وهذا بعتقد شيء طبيعي بظل
حساسيه الموقف وحساسيه
اللحظه السياسيه اللي نحن فيها وتقارب
الاصوات فاذا نكون عم ندرس خياراتنا بشكل
كثير دقيق واتجاهنا اللي حنصوت فيه للمره
الاولى وبعد تجميد منصبه صندوق النقد
الدولي اصدر مرشح المعارضه والتيار الوطني
الحر جهاد ازعور بيانا متوجها فيه الى
ناخبيه قدم نفسه كابن التجربه اللبنانيه
نافيا ان يكون مرشح تحد كما يحلو للثنائي
الشيعي وصفه
بيان ازور اتى بعد كلمه رئاسيه القاها
مرشح الثنائي سليمان فرنجيه وصف خلالها
منافسه بابن المنظومه حزب الله لا ينظر
الى الامن من الزاويه المحلي البحثي هناك
ما يحصل بالاقليم المفاوضات الايرانيه
الامريكيه حول ملف النووي مجددا اتفاق
باكين وغيره من التطورات التي شهدها هذا
الاقليم حزب الله ينتظر تسويه اقليميه عبر
البوابه الايرانيه تحديدا لكي يشرع باتجاه
انتخاب رئيس للجمهوريه من هنا جلسه
الاربعاء هي جلسه تصعيد اعلامي معركه
تحصيل الاصوات ستشكل احراجا لمرشح الثنائي
في حال لم يجاري مرشح المعارضه بتعداد
يلامس الستين صوتا تتجه الانظار ليوم
الاربعاء جلسه لن تكون حاسمه في حرب
الانتخابات الرئاسيه لكن دلالاتها
بالتاكيد ستعيد خلط اوراق كافه الكتل
السياسيه غنوه يتيم العربيه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات